is it crucial to have multiple projects
going at once yes why because like
salmon going upstream a few will get up
there I mean you you have one scripts
not going to do it as always say one
script eventually does open something
like for me my spec opened the door for
assignment work with the company you
know I continued on with that but if you
just focus your energy on one thing it's
it's a it's a lot it's you know the odds
that it's gonna get you you have to be
constantly then that was my problem I'll
share with you when I sold my spec I
didn't have a follow up and that would
that really was a problem because I
thought Here I am and there was no
follow up for a while and that was my
mistake
because I didn't have I wasn't thinking
in those terms you know was early on and
might pursue you know I just did
graduated from college and you know was
not thinking and that structured like
okay this is what's my game plan here
and I knew a friend who went to film
school and he directed a movie that he
wrote but he didn't have a follow up
they spent so much time on this movie it
was a feature and he didn't sell it
it didn't get picked up by anyone he
paid money to show in a theater and they
okay what else you have nothing you know
so you constantly as I say in the book
you have to have ideas that you have to
have long lines that you're working on
then you also have to have some
treatments or one-sheets which are a lot
easier to do than write a complete
screenplay and then you also have to
have your screenplay that you're working
on but constantly when you go into a
meeting with your spec that gets you the
meeting they're not buying that spec
they just want to meet you say oh I can
see your ability and then they say what
else you have and you don't want that to
be well I'm working on something and
it's gonna take me six months I'm not
gonna see you for six months or you're
not gonna be on my radar for six months
you want to say I have this other thing
you don't want to bring you know a
suitcase full of scripts but you want to
say I have this other thing oh well
after the meeting send it over BAM you
know I mean you you have to have
multiple projects in the marketplace I
think at all times because
not all of them and maybe not one of
them but the that's what you're up
against
is to be I don't want to see a machine
but you you know you can't be precious
with I'm only working on one thing for
five years and and you if you have the
luxury of doing that that's great but
you better have a day job to pays you
know if you're you know I didn't want to
wait tables the rest of my life you know
so what motivated me to get out was
continuing to write and create you know
so yeah I think it takes more than one
project you know I know you do a lot of
speaking events this hour I do yeah so
when you have writers approach you
either afterward or even if you see them
at a mixer or something you know when
people ask you for advice and you give
it and you can see that they're
disengaging because they don't want to
hear the answer yes what are some of
those points when you're talking they're
saying hey how do i how do I break into
the industry is there their experience
will be different than mine which it
will be but their experience will be
like oh it's not gonna happen to me
like I said mobray projects in the
marketplace you know and so when people
do that I just say I don't want to
expend any more time bestowing any sort
of advice you know because what's the
point if you're gonna example a friend I
did a favor for a friend I said oh my
friend wrote this TV pilot okay I'll
meet with him now I consult you know on
my off times you know on screenplays and
whatnot I have a consulting business but
I don't but I I only do it when I'm not
working you know because - it's it's not
you know the real jobs or the assignment
jobs so in the down times I open it up
and say you know shops open you know
yeah so I said I'll do this as a freebie
as a favor and a lot of times you get
you it stings you and bites you and that
you know where so I went to meet with
this guy at Starbucks and he brings in a
giant screenplay and I go what is this
he go that's a TV pilot okay and he
starts dropping names of people who I
know that are going to give him an
office in the thing and I was like
they're gonna give you an office what
about me yeah
so I said okay I'll read it so I went
home and there were 10 I'm not kidding
you 10 issues on every page from typos
to format to whatever you want and so we
met again and I was really doing my
friend a favor we met again and he had
an excuse for everyone and wouldn't
listen and I he said well I'm gonna chop
it in half and make it the thing okay
interesting and still went on and I'm
dropping these names about people who I
know are somehow gonna bring him in and
give him a desk in an office and I was
just like I can only do so much you know
good luck to you and maybe I'm wrong I
doubt it but okay people who don't want
to listen
it obviously shows their ignorance and
it's it's I'm not trying to be malicious
I'm just trying to say hey you know I
wish somebody had done that to me and
you know then it would save me a lot of
time and time is what keeps clicking
away you know when you make mistakes why
spend all this time making these
mistakes when you could do it right you
know or go down this path everyone has
to learn hopefully they do but yes I
I've experienced that where they people
just tune off and they're like huh okay
and is that around the time when you say
it's going to take several scripts it's
gonna take always have multiple things
so that if someone that's why I went to
talk at a high school my friends a
teacher to their film class
and one of the kids raises hand goes
you've written have you written any big
movies how long do we have in this yeah
so we went through the thing and you can
just see all this they're not gonna you
know but the few film nerds which I was
one growing up after it was over they
came up three or four great you know
came up and said oh and they wanted to
look at a script and talk to me direct
everybody else couldn't wait to leave
and I just thought huh interesting I was
making films when there was their age
you know doing that and they can do
whatever maybe they weren't interested
that's okay but I always say you'll be
humbled if you're not humble now the
craft and the business
will humble you eventually where you say
oh my one script and then you learn that
you know after 35 screenplays either
you're still learning which you should
be and it takes a lot to get one that's
why the multiple projects thing is
important to have multiple projects
going at each time and then that's to
say you have to write two projects but
always have something you finish one
you're working on another don't believe
these long gaps you know of nothing and
you're out there and my spec that I sold
it took seven years but I didn't that
wasn't my only thing I had I wasn't
running around town with this one spec I
continued on doing other things I I was
in a sketch comedy show I was doing
proactive things at the same time but
the only problem is that once is sold I
didn't have a specific spec like in the
same genre where they could say what
else can I look at where things weren't
ready you know it's important to to have
those those other things ready because
like I said if you have that meeting and
they say oh send over something you
don't want it to be six months later you
want it to be you know immediate
immediately
you